hey fellow Geeks it's Daniel and today
we have the Galaxy Z fold in hand this
thing runs in adrenal 730 for GPU and a
Snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 for its CPU and
we're going to be playing Apex Legends
Genji impact Call of Duty mobile and
Diablo so let's get into gaming okay so
first game we're going to play is
genshin impact so let's just get into it
okay so just checking all of our
settings
everything's on the highest
UH 60 FPS as you can see so we're all
good to go
foreign
fast travel there real quick
all right this weather is perfect we
should move out
so the reason why we're monster is
because there are more NPCs here and
small cup two texting on the GPU and so
far there are a couple of things drops
here and there again we're recording
this at 120 FPS so you guys can see the
frame rate drop when it dies
so far a couple here and there but
nothing oh yeah that was a big one
screw around a bit more
[Applause]
there you go
see obviously the vault is in the gaming
Centric phone with an adrenal 730 in
there but
it does the job
[Applause]
okay so let's check the front
[Applause]
we're only about 38 degrees ish around
here on both screens
okay this side is definitely closer to
where the chip is at
the same goes with this side oh no
really actually so it's mostly just the
heat supposedly just around here
on this side of the phone
all right back down here it's about
89.5 38 yeah it's getting pretty hot
actually
crowned air
and we have not got to do any fights yet
so let's
just keep playing
right loading times in between
the different areas is pretty quick
okay let's go
[Applause]
nice
[Applause]
okay so far no frame rate drops when it
comes to fighting ish
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah they're doing kind of well we just
had a little framing drop on here but
nothing to be concerned about I guess
it's not that bad actually it's just
that the back is heating up quite a bit
[Applause]
[Music]
okay let's go to the abyss real quick
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
and there we go let's do a final
temperature check we didn't have that
many frame rate drops until it got to
the Altis or when the place got a little
bit too busy let's check the front
actually
foreign
[Music]
somewhere on here
[Music]
check the back again
[Applause]
39 degrees 38 degrees
it's about 38 degrees 39 degrees 40
degrees on the back down here so
yeah this thing is really hot but the
rest of the phone is fine
[Applause]
it honestly is okay so next game next
game is Apex Legends
so you lose games back to back so the
thing is you know you want to see how
much we can push this thing
[Music]
[Applause]
okay let's just all right let's check
out settings real quick
sit there and then go to graphics
extreme HD very Ultra frame rate
adaptive smoothing not sure why not
display the FPS
because we can these things off
anti-aliasing off turn that off
Bloom is on and we are good to go
[Applause]
[Music]
all right let's just get into a match
[Applause]
okay let's just go
shoot down
[Applause]
yep
but can you expect it you know
[Music]
it tastes really smooth actually
for now
so yeah yeah I kind of like probably
like
the area
[Applause]
of course it's ready to go
[Applause]
oh
[ __ ] no kill leader right here oh
safe space
[Applause]
executions are smooth at least
[Applause]
okay for a while because I haven't
really noticed any like major freeway
drops or anything so let's just check
the temperature real quick
on the front
it's about 39-ish it's it's pretty much
the same as playing engine
so
that's the comfortable to play it's fine
[Applause]
[Applause]
order into our safe space
[Applause]
replicator being delivered well let's
end this session here but before we end
it uh let's check the temperature
[Applause]
it's still about the same it's the same
thing as thinking okay maybe there is a
little
Spike about like one or two degrees on
certain parts of the phone let's check
the back
yeah still pretty much the same
and honestly I haven't really noticed
the Heat
that much because like you know it's
it's honestly really comfortable to play
around
with the phone so far so let's move on
to the next game that's going through
hot mobile
let's get into Call of Duty mobile
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
all right set things real quick
[Music]
very high let's go Ultra multiplayer
and the other thing is on let's just
take everything that can't turn on so
yeah it's going to be prioritizing
oh yeah okay so you can't do the highest
graphic quality the highest frame rate
so we'll just do this instead
and you can ragdoll
bloom in just a few long just turn
everything on and
let's play
all right this is deer's one
[Applause]
there we go
[Music]
[Applause]
it plays really well
um no noticeable frame drops from the
get-go
at any point of time actually so quick
temperature check I think it went down
so as you can see it's about 36 degrees
where the chip should be at and the rest
of the phone is a cooled down quite
quickly actually
yeah
yeah let's check the back
yeah about 36 ish on the so this phone
can actually dissipate heat pretty well
when it comes to long-term gaming
[Applause]
[Music]
there we go
so yeah
thank you
enemy down
enemies
[Applause]
how's the needing to tweak the controls
a little bit and getting used to the
screen you know it's
shop gameplay and everything it's pretty
smooth I mean there wasn't any
noticeable frame job so I don't think
there weren't any at all and the phone
is still like you know cool for the
touch so let's do a final temperature
check just to check it out
yeah about 36 degrees on this side where
the chip is at and then 35 around here
yeah about like 36 35 around here
so not too bad not Chevy at all
the back
it's about yeah I actually went down
yeah it went no the temperature went
down wow okay
all right
final game let's go with Diablo
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay now that we're in Diablo let's just
get in to the game it's with Doc I'm
just brighten it up a little bit
there we go okay
so I just started the game
and let's set the settings up real quick
[Applause]
Graphics 60 FPS Ultra
and this device currently cannot support
it but expect it to be able to support
it in future updates
image opening
sure why not and yeah let's go
oh again it's beautiful though okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
and outsider
I mean a couple free drops here and
there but I don't think
like so far in the combat but so far in
this fight that I can do only focusable
ones
oh
I received imagery
never mind
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm done
there we go
all right so let's do a final
temperature check
[Applause]
City it is they're about
on the other side that is 635
we are holding up pretty well right now
actually and again it's really
comfortable to play with even though
it's like 38 around here it doesn't it
doesn't affect the entire phone because
you know it's so wide and because it's
so light you know it can pretty much
handle heat very well let's check the
back
about 3736 34 around the bottom as well
can handle games pretty well so the
Samsung Galaxy z44 candle itself pretty
well when it comes to a number of games
and if you guys want to see how the
nothing phone handles our gaming test
you guys can click right here
[Music]